[Music]
so now I'm going to show you four cool
tricks you can practice at home okay so
this first one hasn't really got
anything to do with table tennis but
it's a cool party trick and all you need
is one table tennis ball so the idea is
to create a trap of air between your
hands so when you hit it the ball will
pop out and it makes a cool sound and
this one is actually not that difficult
if you know the technique so the first
step is to wrap your fingers around the
ball so no air can slip through once you
have found the grip you create a cup
with the rest of your fingers the most
important thing is not to squeeze the
ball hard it just has to be really
gently on top just so it covers
everything
otherwise it won't come off when you hit
but if it's gently there it comes off
another thing is you don't hit it with
your hand the hand isn't hitting the
ball and yeah it's the pressure that
pops it out so all you need is a gentle
tap if you have the right grip
[Music]
so this next one is actually quite good
practice for ball control
the idea is to roll the ball onto the
other side of the racket without the
ball bouncing and of course if you're a
beginner there's a lot of easy
variations if you want to start off with
these and basically anything you do with
the racket on the ball is good practice
for control they can come up with
whatever variations you want okay so
this one won't make you a better table
tennis player but it makes you into a
cooler tilt let's play so all it is is
just one spin on your finger and to do
this you give speed with your wrist and
just spin it over and catch with your
thumb it's also important to spin it
counterclockwise because if you spin it
clockwise it's a lot harder to catch ya
know doesn't work so you spin it this
way and if you want to take it further
you can do the double spin triple spin
it's maybe best to practice this on top
of something soft maybe this isn't so
you so useless after all
you could come up with a cool serve to
fool your opponent or something or maybe
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this one is quite hard to do but if you
can generate spin it's not that hard to
catch it with your nails if you want to
practice put in spin on the ball you can
do it for example on the table just get
below the ball and hit it to the side
this is also a really good practice for
controlling the ball and understanding
how spin works so with your nails you
form a sort of circle you don't even
need to use all five fingers I use four
because it just feels more natural and
after that all you need to do is to
catch it on your nails if you want to
put even more spin on the ball you can
throw the ball at the racket and then
catch it this is also a pretty useful
way to check if the ball is round
because if the ball is round it's not
going to wobble or it's gonna have a
smooth spin and it also you can hear it
from the sound so for example this ball
is really bad it wobbles and this one is
good it's a clean spin
[Music]
so hope you guys learn something and got
some fire dears to practice until next
time triple spin oh so close
1 2 3